no no I'm straight up Twitter right now
has the right to ban all any protected
class twitter can say you know we're not
gonna allow any Asians on the platform
boo my my reading of that of so I know
that there's court testimony that you
tweeted which I reviewed and I've
reviewed the context of that and some
legal opinions that's not the opinion
that I came away with the opinion that I
came away with is not and let me see if
I can I'll distinguish it the way I
understand it and then you tell me if
I'm maybe misunderstanding it my reading
of the test and and this may be getting
sort of too in the weeds for some in the
audience maybe not but we'll give it a
shot
my understanding of the testimony that
you linked me to is that it is not that
Twitter could say as a policy we do not
allow Asian people on our platform I've
seen no serious legal opinion that that
is something Twitter would be able to do
my understanding is that if there is a
type of speech that Twitter identifies
that would disproportionately rap up
Asian people that that is something
Twitter is asserting would be legally
acceptable in terms of in in terms of
that particular testimony yeah but as we
know from the motherboard piece at least
one employee said they use an algorithm
to sweep up Muslim his target Isis which
actually sweeps up innocent Muslims but
that's exactly the point I'm making
which is that's not them Twitter is not
saying as a policy we don't allow
Muslims they're saying we have a policy
to target Isis which is mostly made up
of Muslims which will trigger some false
positives so I guess that the challenge
then is are reinforcing rules at a
policy level or an individual level if I
agree we completely that's that's
actually that's a key question but I
don't want anybody to think that what
you're asserting unless it is what
you're asserting with that yeah good so
let's let's let's let's dig into it um
what is the Twitter public accommodation
that you can say something and it will
appear in reverse chronological order to
those who subscribe to it right right
that is the public accommodation
according to civil rights law you cannot
restrict a public accommodation based on
productive characteristics if someone
quotes a verse from the Quran Twitter
can remove that okay so you're saying at
the individual level or through an
algorithm that is meant to identify they
can they know like
a Twitter employee has the First
Amendment and section 230 right to say
anything pertaining to this protected
class we can remove because Twitter is
the thing that so here's where I think
and I don't know if we're talking past
each other or if we actually disagree
about what the policy is or if we're
just misunderstanding what the policy is
what I'm saying is I have seen no
evidence nor any legal opinion nor have
I seen Twitter say that they believe
they could have a policy that says we do
not allow for example Jews on Twitter
and that would be legal so yeah so let's
try and break to the real world okay the
way you're describing it would be that
McDonald says no no you know Jews are
allowed in the store we just refused to
sell them cheeseburgers you see I mean
the point the point of view we're not
sure that that's the phone allergy so
let's check it out Twitter is a platform
where you can express your thoughts okay
you can go on and you can otherwise what
are you really doing nothing like
there's literally that's all Twitter
does Twitter has a first amendment
second and section 230 argument where
they say whatever it is you say we can
remove it for any reason and the judge
asked are you saying you could remove
someone even if it would be
discriminatory based on religion or
gender and the response from Twitter's
lawyers was yes right so that the I just
think I think you're misunderstanding
that testimony and there's a page that
follows it or a sequence that follows it
that I think is very illuminating I'll
just give an example and maybe the exact
the analogy will may allow us to move
forward on this
imagine that Twitter wants to I mean
let's just take the one from from we
were talking about earlier Twitter wants
to enforce a ban on anti-semitic content
okay
let's imagine that that's something
Twitter decided they were going to do
anti-semitic content on Twitter is not
equally balanced between men and women
we don't even have to argue about what
the split is but we would just agree
it's very unlikely that it's 50/50 or
fifty point three and forty nine point
seven the way that men and women exist
in society anti-semitic content on
Twitter is not evenly balanced between
right-wingers and left wingers
they'll study says 71% is right wing
number doesn't matter you might disagree
with the number but let's just imagine
yeah it's not evenly distributed what
Twitter is asserting is if indeed 71% of
anti-semitic content comes from
right-wingers we are going to be
disproportionately removing the content
of and banning conservatives or
right-wingers yeah whatever term you
want to use is not saying we would
legally be able to say no imagine that
they're white conservatives just for our
argument because we got to add a
protected class Twitter is not saying if
we wanted to ban all white conservatives
from Twitter we would be allowed to do
it that would violate a very specific
non-discrimination law what they are
saying is that if the practice of
removing anti-semitic content
disproportionately targets people who
happen to be white as long as we're not
removing people for being white that is
legal and I agree that that's legal
that's a really interesting that's a
good point it's a really good point what
we're seeing now I think with the
digital space is that we've actually got
a distinction between people as thoughts
and the thoughts related to certain
characteristics and identities and the
individual themself and identity because
I think by your explanation and again I
think it's a good point
Twitter couldn't actually ban someone
for being gay because they're banning
the speech specifically right
no like if so well put this way yeah if
someone if someone was gay and made a
post talking about the things they do as
a gay person Twitter could ban them
right well I don't I mean I guess if
they had a policy that said what that
you can't talk about gay things I don't
know no I'm saying like from a legal
from a legal standpoint based on the the
First Amendment argument that Twitter is
under no obligation to support the
speech of anyone else right so if you're
saying so let's Twitter does have a
policy that bans hate speech which means
because like you said it's predominantly
coming from one side they predominately
get banned all right well and we're
speaking hypothetically sound other
numbers but but for the sake we it's
again I think it's a good point you're
it's something I and realized there is
going to be a distinction between the
individuals identity and the ideas the
ideas don't have an identity right so
are you are you agreeing that you
certain that Twitter claims they can ban
people on the basis of protected classes
it was not an accurate reading I think I
think you're correct but I do want to
clarify I think what we're actually
seeing is that there are certain ideas
associated with identity politics yes
and that twitter has the ability to
remove ideas around certain groups that
are specific to that group for instance
I agree